i think we're all reasonably familiar
with the three states of matter in our
everyday world they're at very high
temperatures you get a fourth but the
three ones that we normally deal with
are are things could be a solid
a liquid i'll do that in
blue although it doesn't have to be blue
or it could be a gas
and we have this general notion and i
think
water is the example that always comes
to at least my mind is that solid
happens when things are colder
relatively colder
and then as you warm up
you go into a liquid state and as you
warm up even more you go into a gaseous
state so you go from colder to hotter
and in the case of water when you're a
solid you are
you're when you're solid your ice
when you're liquid your you could i mean
you know some people would call ice
water but let's call it liquid water
liquid water i think we know what that
is liquid water
and then when it's in the gas state
you're essentially you are vapor or
steam
vapor
vapor or steam so let's think a little
bit about what what at least in the case
of water and the the analogy will extend
to other types of molecules but what is
it about water that makes it solid and
when it's colder what allows it to be
liquid and i'll be frank some liquids
are are kind of fascinating because you
know you can never kind of uh you can
never nail them down i guess is the best
way to view them or or gas so let's just
draw a water molecule
water molecule so you have
oxygen there
you have
some bonds to hydrogen
and then you have two extra pairs of
valence electrons in the oxygen and we
did a couple of videos ago we said hey
oxygen is a lot more electronegative
than the than the hydrogen that it likes
to hog the electrons so even though that
you know this shows that they're they're
sharing
electrons here and here right at both
sides of those lines you can kind of
view that you know hydrogen's
contributing electron and oxygen is
contributing electron on both sides of
that line but we know because of the
electro negativity or the relative
electronegativity of oxygen that it's
hogging these electrons and so the
electrons spend a lot more time around
the oxygen than they do around the
hydrogen and what that results is is
that on the oxygen side of the molecule
you end up with a partial negative
charge
and we talked about that a little bit on
the hydrogen sides of the molecules you
end up with a slightly positive charge
you end up with a slightly positive
charge
right there slightly positive
now if you have very little
i i guess the best things if these
molecules have very little kinetic
energy they're not moving around a whole
lot then what these these the the
positive sides of the hydrogens are very
attracted to the negative sides of
oxygen in other molecules so let me draw
some more molecules so when we talk
about the whole state of the whole
matter we actually think about
how the molecules are interacting with
each other not just how the atoms are
interacting with each other within a
molecule so let's say that
i just drew one oxygen let me copy and
paste that
cold face but i could do multiple
oxygens and let's say that that hydrogen
is going to have a is going to want to
be near this oxygen because this has
partial negative charge this has a
partial positive charge
and then i could do
another one
right there
and then maybe we'll have and just to
kind of make the point clear you know
you have two hydrogens here maybe an
oxygen wants to hang out there i'll do
it in the so maybe have an oxygen
that wants to be here because it's got
its
it's got its partial negative here and
it's connected to two hydrogens
right there that have their partial
positive but you can kind of see a
lattice structure be you know let me
draw the let me draw this these bonds
that these polar bonds that start
forming between the
particles
and these bonds they're called polar
bonds because the molecules themselves
are polar as you can see it forms this
lattice structure and if the if the each
of these molecules don't have a lot of
kinetic energy or if we say the average
kinetic energy of this of this of this
matter is fairly low and what do we know
is average kinetic energy well that's
temperature
then this lattice structure will be
solid
solid these these molecules will not
move relative to each other they're all
you know i could draw a gazillion more
but i think you get the point that we're
forming this kind of
this this this fixed structure
and while we're in the solid state as we
add kinetic energy as we add heat
what it does to the molecules it just
makes them vibrate around a little bit
so the kinetic energy just makes these
you know if i was a cartoonist how the
way you draw like a vibration is put
little quotation marks there that's not
very scientific but they would vibrate
around they would they would buzz around
a little bit i'm drawing arrows to show
that they're vibrating doesn't have to
be just left right it could be up down
but as you add more and more heat in a
solid
these molecules are going to keep their
structure so they're not going to move
around relative to each other but they
will they will convert that heat when
heat is just a form of energy into
kinetic energy which is expressed in
these
as as the vibration of these molecules
now if you kind of if you make these
molecules start to vibrate enough and if
you put enough kinetic energy into these
molecules what do you think is going to
happen well this guy is vibrating pretty
hard and he's vibrating harder and
harder as you add more and more heat
this guy is doing the same thing at some
point these polar bonds that they have
to each other are going to start not
being strong enough to contain the
vibrations right and once that happens
once that happens the molecules let me
draw a couple more
once that happens the molecules are
going to start moving past each other
right they'll start moving past each
other
so now all of a sudden the molecule will
start shifting
the molecule will start shifting but
they're still attracted to maybe the
side is moving here that's moving there
you have other molecules moving around
that way but they are still attracted to
each other right even though the we've
gotten to the kinetic energy to the
point that the vibrations can kind of
break the bonds can break these these
the bonds between the polar sides of the
molecules
it's still our vibration or our kinetic
energy animal on for each molecule still
isn't strong enough to completely
separate them they're starting to slide
past each other and this is how
essentially what happens when you're in
a liquid state is that you have a lot of
atoms that are just they want to be
touching each other but they're sliding
they have enough kinetic energy to slide
past each other and break that solid
that solid lattice structure here and
then if you add even more kinetic energy
even more heat to the to the to the at
this point it's a solution now
you're going to break they're not even
going to be able to stay together
they're not going to be able to stay
near each other if you had enough
kinetic energy they're going to start
looking like this they're going to
completely separate and then kind of
bounce around independently
especially independently if they're an
ideal gas but
but in general a gas is they're no
longer touching each other they you know
maybe they might bump into each other
but they have so much kinetic energy on
their own
that they're all doing their own thing
and they're not touching
and i think that makes kind of intuitive
sense if you just think about what a gas
you know
you for example it's hard to see a gas
why is it hard to see a gas because the
molecules are much further apart so
they're not they're not they're not
acting on the light as in the way that a
that a liquid or a solid would and if we
keep thinking making that extension
further a solid well i probably
shouldn't use the example with with ice
because
ice or water is one of the few
situations where the solid is less dense
than the liquid that's why ice floats
and that's why icebergs don't just all
fall to the bottom of the ocean and and
ponds don't completely freeze solid
but
you can imagine that because
a liquid is in most cases other than
water less dense that's another reason
why you can see through it a little bit
better or it's not diffracting well i
won't go into that too much uh then
maybe even a solid but the gas is the
most obvious is that and it is true with
water
the liquid form is definitely more dense
than the gas form that the gas form will
kind of the molecules are just going to
jump around not touch each other and
because of that more light can kind of
get through the substance
now the question is how do we measure
the amount of heat that it takes
the amount of heat that it takes to do
this to water
and to explain that i'll actually draw a
phase change diagram which is a fancy
way of describing something fairly
fairly straightforward so let me say
that this is the amount of heat i'm
adding
and this is the temperature and we'll
talk about the states of matter in a
second
so heat is often denoted by q
sometimes people will talk it well you
know change in heat they'll use h
lowercase uppercase h they'll put a
delta in front of the h delta just means
change in and sometimes you'll hear the
word entholpy and let me write that
because it was a word that i used to you
know i'd say what is enthalpy they
sounds like they're using it enthalpy
it sounds like empathy but it's it's
quite a different concept at least as
far as my neural connections can make it
but enthalpy is kind of it is closely
related to heat it's heat content
it's heat whoops
it's heat content
heat content for our purposes when you
hear someone say change in enthalpy you
should really just be thinking of change
in heat i think this word was really
just introduced to
to to confuse chemistry students and
introduce a non-intuitive
word into their vocabulary the best way
to think about it is heat content change
in enthalpy is really just changing heat
and just remember you know all of these
things whether we're talking about heat
you know kinetic energy
potential energy
enthalpy they you know you'll hear them
in different contexts you're like oh i
thought i should be using heat and
they're talking about enthalpy or these
are all forms of energy
and these are all measured in joules
and they might be measured in other ways
but the the traditional way is joules
and energy is the ability to do work and
if you what's the what's the unit for
work well it's joules force times
distance but anyway that's a side note
but it's good to know this word enthalpy
especially in a chemistry context
because it's used all the time it can be
very confusing and non-intuitive because
you're like where did this enthalpy what
you know i don't know what enthalpy is
in my everyday life let's just think of
it as heat content because that's that's
really what it is but anyway on this
axis i have temperature or no i have
heat right so this is when i have very
little heat and i'm increasing my heat
and this say is temperature
temperature
temperature now let's say at at low
temperatures i'm here and as i as i add
heat my temperature will go up right
temperature is average kinetic energy
let's say i'm in the solid state here
and i'll do the solid state in purple
and so as i add heat
i already was using purple i'll use
i'll use magenta
so as i add heat my temperature will go
up right heat is a form of energy and
when i add it to these molecules as i
did in this example what did it do it
made them vibrate more or it made them
have higher kinetic energy or higher
average kinetic energy and that's what
temperature is a measure of average
kinetic energy
so as i add heat in the solid phase my
average kinetic energy will go up and
let me write this down this is in the
solid phase
or the solid state
of matter now something very interesting
happens and let's say this is water
let's say there's water
so what what happens at at
this is zero degrees i'll do zero
or which is also
273.15 kelvin
0 degrees celsius but let's say that's
that line what happens to
a solid
well it turns into a liquid ice melts
and not all solids we're talking in
particular about water about h2o so if
we're so this is ice in our example all
solids aren't ice although you know you
could you could think of you could think
of a rock as solid magma because that's
what it is right you can think of um i
mean we could i could take that analogy
a bunch of different ways but an
interesting thing that happens is
at 100 degree or at a zero degrees right
the the the
depending on what direction you're going
either the freezing point of water or
the melting point of ice something
interesting happens
as i add more heat
i the temperature does not go up
as i add more heat the temperature does
not go up for a little period
let me draw that
for a little period the temperature
stays constant
so and then and then while the
temperature is constant it stays a solid
we're still a solid and then we finally
turn into a liquid
then we finally turn into a liquid let's
say right there so we added a certain
amount of heat and just stayed a solid
but it got us to the point that the ice
turned into a liquid it was kind of
melting the entire time that's the best
way to think about it and then once we
keep adding more and more heat then the
liquid warms up too so then the liquid
the liquid warms up
now we get to
what temperature becomes interesting
again for water well obviously 100 100
degrees celsius or 373
let me draw it like this or 373 degrees
kelvin i'll do it in celsius because
that's what we're familiar with what
happens that's that's the heat that's
the temperature at which water will
vaporize or which water will boil but
something happens
and you know why is it you know it's
they're really getting energy uh
kinetically
active
but i just like when you went from solid
to liquid there's a certain amount of
energy that you have to contribute to
the system and actually it's a good it's
a good amount at this point
where the water
is turning into vapor but it's not
getting any hotter
so it's turning into vapor but it's not
getting any hotter so you have we had to
keep adding heat but notice the
temperature didn't go up and we're going
to talk about in a second what what was
happening then and then finally
after that point where
we're completely vaporized or we're
completely steam
then we can start getting hot the steam
can then get hotter as we add more and
more
heat to the system
so the interesting question i think it's
intuitive that as you add heat
as you add heat here we're going to get
our temperature is going to go up but
the interesting thing is what was going
on here we were adding heat so over here
we're turning our heat into kinetic
energy temperature is average kinetic
energy but over here what was our heat
doing well our heat was was not adding
kinetic energy to the system it was the
temperature was not increasing but the
ice was going from ice to water
so what was happening at that state
is that the kinetic energy
the the heat was being used to
essentially break these bonds
to break these bonds and essentially
bring the molecules into a higher energy
state so you know you're saying sal what
does that mean higher energy state well
if there wasn't all of this heat and all
this kinetic energy these molecules want
to be very close to each other right for
example i want to be close to the
surface of the earth when you put me in
a plane you have put me in a higher
energy state i have a lot more potential
energy i have the potential to fall
towards the earth likewise when you move
these molecules apart and you go from a
solid to a liquid they want to fall
towards each other but because they have
so much kinetic energy they never quite
are able to do it but their energy goes
up their relative their potential energy
is higher because they want to fall
towards each other by falling towards
each other in theory they could do some
work so what's happening here is
is when we're
when when we're contributing heat and
this actually this amount of heat we're
contributing it it's you know we could
either call it when you're going in it's
called the heat of fusion
heat of fusion
because it's the same amount of heat
regardless of how much direction we go
in when we go from solid to liquid it's
kind of we can view it as the heat of
melting right it takes it's the heat
that you need to put in to melt it the
ice into liquid when you're going in
this direction it's the heat you have to
take out of the zero degree water to
turn it into ice so it's the heat that
you're so you're taking that potential
energy and you're bringing the molecules
closer and closer to each other so here
so the way to think about it is
right here this heat is being converted
to kinetic energy then
when we're when we're at this phase
change from solid to liquid the heat is
being used to add potential energy into
the system to pull the mark the to pull
the molecules apart to give them more
potential energy if you pull me apart
from the earth you're giving me
potential energy because i gravity wants
to pull me back to the earth and i could
do work when i'm falling back to the
earth i could i don't know you know a
waterfall does work it can move a
turbine i could you could have a bunch
of falling cells move a turbine as well
and then once you are fully liquid then
you just become a warmer and warmer
liquid now now the heat is once again
being used for kinetic energy
right you're making the water molecules
move past each other faster and faster
and faster
to some point where they wanna
they wanna just completely disassociate
from each other they wanna not even
slide past each other just completely
jump away from each other
and that's right here this is the heat
of vaporization
so this is
the heat of vaporization
heat of
vaporization and that the same idea is
happening before we were sliding next to
each other now we're pulling them apart
all together so we're so they could they
could definitely fall closer together
and then once we've added this much heat
now we are we are we're we're just
heating up the steam we're just heating
up the gaseous water and it's just
getting hotter and hotter and hotter but
the interesting thing there and i mean
at least the interesting thing to me
when i first learned is that there are
these states that you can have whenever
i think of zero degrees water i would
say oh it must be ice but that's not
necessarily the case if you start with
water and you make it colder and colder
and colder
to zero degrees you're essentially
taking heat out of the water you can
have zero degree water and it hasn't
turned into ice yet and likewise you
could have 100 degree water that hasn't
turned into steam yet you have to add
more energy you can also have 100 degree
steam you can also have
zero degree water
anyway hopefully that gives you a little
bit of intuition of what the different
states of matter are and in the next
problem we'll talk about how much heat
exactly it does take to to move along
this line and maybe we can solve some
problems on you know how much ice we
might need to make our drink cool